[music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Stay with
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences and
the individual results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options [music] available. We are
honored to have a founding father of the
science of epigenetics guiding us with
the best options to obtain or maintain
optimal health, Dr. Joel Wallach.
[music]
This
Let's go ahead and open up the Zoom
room. Hello, everybody, and welcome.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca. My
name is Becca Duke. As the hostess of
this program, I am honored to be able to
present to you information that is
empowering.
So many places in this world, so many
establishments want to take away our
power. Well, guess what?
We are empowered individuals, and we can
make decisions
based on our health goals.
And you know, all the information out
there
doesn't necessarily
um give us the results we want.
So, there have been things and fads that
say, you know, do this, this, and this
for better health. And I tried them, and
I
I got sicker. So, anyways, this program
is to provide information that I found
to be the solution to all of my health
issues and the health issues of
thousands and thousands, if not hundreds
of thousands or millions, others as
well. So, without any further delay, I
just want to remind you that if somebody
shared this program with you
specifically, get back with them.
Okay?
If you saw a link on somebody's page,
social media page, then get back with
them. Reach out to them, say, "Hey,
thank you so much for sharing that link.
I watched, and this is what I loved most
about what I heard." And if you have any
questions, they are going to be your
first point of contact. If there is
nobody to thank, then you absolutely are
welcome to reach out to us at Daily with
Doc. We do have a call team standing by
for your calls at 855-949-3377.
We also have a website as this program
is being sponsored by dailywithdoc.com.
That website is dailywithdoc.com.
On our website, you're going to find a
good foods, bad foods list. That's
something I get a lot. What should I
eat? What shouldn't I eat? Well,
we are all based on the research of Dr.
Joel Wallach, who is our doc for the
day.
And what he has found to be the
healthiest, closest to nature diet
that promotes good health rather than
causing more digestive issues and
hindering absorption of nutrition. So,
look for that good foods, bad foods list
on the website at dailywithdoc.com.
We also have articles to help give you
more tools in your toolbox.
And also,
some of our best replays are there on
our Daily with Doc show uh website as
well. And a store. So, if you're not
working with anybody and you hear
something that you like, today we're
going to be talking about our pets. So,
absolutely,
you can find products on our website by
clicking on that store option from the
menu.
Well, today we're going to be asking Dr.
Wallach to put on his veterinarian hat,
which is where this all started,
and talk about pets.
So,
you know, it's crazy when we look at
how animals make such a positive impact
in our lives.
And we want to take care of them.
Just as we want to take care of our
children.
And from 2021 to 2022, there was 11%
increase
in wellness expenses to take care of our
pets alone. Whether it's a sick pet or
emergency care, it didn't matter.
The cost for
cats
for just wellness care is between $374
and $965.
And for dogs,
$534
to 100 or 1,285.
That's per year, annually, folks.
Well, we can't always predict
what's going to happen in our pets'
lives, just like we can't for our
children, because disease is not
genetic. But,
we can support their bodies just as we
support our bodies, so that we can
function optimally.
Now, I mentioned the 11% increase.
So, if you take from 2022,
where there was 136.8
billion
dollars spent on taking care of our
pets,
and that's essential pet expenses.
Annually per pet is $1,533.
You can buy a whole lot of nutrition for
your pets and avoid having to
take them
to a facility for unnecessary sickness.
And that's what we're going to learn
about today. Because as we look through
the different elements that affect pets,
they get the same things that we do.
They get cancer. They get blood sugar
issues. They get eye issues. They get
bone issues, like arthritis. They break
bones, too. They have dental issues,
urinary tract
issues, kidney issues, heart issues,
skin issues, ear infections, ligament
issues, growths, tumors, seizures,
x-rays, and even overnight
hospitalizations.
So,
when I look at that and I think about
how my life was with children before
really finding the solution in
nutrition,
uh we were looking at a lot of those
different things for myself and my
family. And now,
we invest into ourselves and our
wellness and
intentionally supplement, not having to
do those
emergency visits, or not even
Well, sometimes there's emergency
visits, yeah.
But, you know, overall,
we're in great health,
and
we're going to stay that way. So, let's
keep our pets that way,
as well. And I can't think of a better
person
to join me in talking about taking care
of our pets,
than Dr. Joel Wallach, who has a
Bachelor of Science in agriculture and
plant and soil uh sciences, and a Doctor
of Veterinary Medicine.
He actually was part of and the lead
pathologist and veterinarian in an
expedition to save the white rhino.
This is back in the '60s.
So, it's not like he's new to the the
screen, folks. Especially not new to
making an impact in the lives of all
animals, humans alike. He
has his very first publication, which
I think this is the first one, maybe the
second one, which is held as a national
treasure. This was his college thesis,
folks.
Diseases of Exotic Animals: Medical and
Surgical Management.
This is going through 451
different species
of animals, and the autopsies that he
performed on
amphibians, vertebrates, all the above.
And is used in veterinary schools
in teaching them how to
really look at taking care of the
animals that the veterinarians are
looking at.
So, if I could get to the screen with
me, the
best
veterinarian
in the world
who wanted to go be on animals and reach
this human animal kind,
Dr. Joel Wallach. Now, Dr. Wallach,
welcome to Daily with Doc. You are the
reason I do this show. You are also the
reason I'm able
physically to do this show, and
mentally.
So, I just want to say, thank you for
all that you do,
and you know, you're still, even though
you have made such a huge impact in the
human lives,
you have not forgotten about the animals
and our pets and our fur babies and our
feather babies, either. Or, our reptile
babies.
You want to go all the way.
So, Doc,
welcome. How are you today?
Thank you very much for the kind kind
kind
introduction.
And um yeah, it's been a blessing.
Um and I have to thank um
uh Creflo Dollar,
okay, who was
director of the St. Louis Zoo,
okay? And um
>> Creflo Dollar was?
Oh, no.
>> it was I thought it was Marlin Perkins.
Who?
Marlin Perkins. Yeah, Marlin Perkins.
Yes, excuse me.
Okay.
>> And I want to thank him
because he let me [clears throat] do uh
autopsies at the St. Louis Zoo,
uh and taking the, you know, tissues and
chemistry to the University of Missouri
and Washington University.
This is um
in the the late '50s and early '60s,
okay?
And so, um we were really,
what should I say?
The
the whole idea
was to
help the animals in the zoos live
longer, instead of just living for 6
months or a year or two,
um
we helped them live 25 years, 30 years,
40 years, 50 years, 100 years. And so,
we're very very happy about that.
And we had
um
three major grants,
three major grants. I had three
three post-doctoral fellowships.
And we're doing thousands of autopsies
in each one of those projects,
and that was one of the first ones, um
the Diseases of Exotic Animals.
Yeah, and um
it's uh let's see, I think it was like a
a $12 million grant,
which is huge amount of money for little
dumb farm boy from Missouri.
Okay? Well, and one thing that I didn't
mention, folks, is the original of this
publication is held in the Smithsonian
Museum as a national treasure.
So, we have on with us the author of a
national treasure, who is a national
treasure in himself, and I think it's
goes more into international treasure,
worldwide treasure, Dr. Wallach, because
your work has been done around the
world.
Well, thank you. And again, I have to
thank Marlin Perkins for
>> [clears throat]
>> every time something happened somewhere
in the world, he'd miss he'd send me
there.
And so, that's how I I got so many
things going on from back then. It was
like 30 different countries,
and um I would get animals that died in
those countries, and they would freeze
them and send them to me in St. Louis
Zoo,
uh Washington University in St. Louis.
Uh I had all access to their pathology
department and all their equipment and
>> [clears throat]
>> all their great scientists who taught me
how,
before I even got into really advanced
uh veterinary
um pathology studies, they were teaching
me how to read the the microscopic
slides and all that kind of stuff. So,
it was really a
quite a a thing.
Well, Dr. Wallach, you also wrote a book
about rhinos and your expedition in
saving saving the rhinos, which I have
right here. It's a It's a
It's just a sweet little
um kind of adventure book.
Yeah, so,
why Rhino Express?
At the time, there was only
actually actual counting in Africa,
there was like 350 alive white rhinos,
and I caught
>> And now there's 1,500.
>> Uh with a with a um
drug,
um
it was called M99. They didn't even have
a name for it. It was called M99. One
drop
one drop could knock down
a 600-lb rhino.
Okay, so my
darts that I would use to to catch them,
the darts were the size of the little
bitty 1-in long, 1/4-in diameter
uh batteries that you put in your
flashlight, or not your flashlight, but
in your car keys or something like that.
And um
uh
it it shows you in this book, it shows
you catching them, shows you shows them
loading them up in the boxes.
And then we had to teach them for 68
weeks how to live in that box.
And then once they could live in the
box,
we'd tranquilize them,
put them on a boat, and send them to
some other country in the world. There
There you go.
Just two or three drops of that that
M99, it's called etorphine, they gave it
a name finally, etorphine.
Um just two or three drops in there
would knock down a 600-lb rhino.
You did not want to accidentally shoot
yourself with that.
Well, I can't imagine.
You You may not wake up for
weeks. You might not ever wake up again.
Wow. Well, Dr. Wallach,
you did that because of wanting to save
a species from extinction from
extinction.
>> we wanted to save that species.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> that species went way back into some of
the earliest of large mammals, you know,
like white rhino, black rhino, or
talking about hippos, we're talking
about elephants, and so forth, those
kinds of things.
And so, it was really
terrible
that there was more
um
rabbits in the world than white rhino.
And they they came around in the early
early early days of the earth, and they
were the creatures on earth.
And the fact that we are
um mammals, we're cousins to the white
rhino, just like we're cousins to
gorillas, we're cousins to cows, we're
cousins to sheep, we're cousins to dogs
and cats. We're going to talk about dogs
and cats today.
Well, Doc, I love the fact that um
you have not kept a closed mind, and you
have opened things up to
to
even though you've moved on to humans
and wanted to focus on humans, you still
have that knowledge and that love to
help families, even their fur babies,
stay healthy.
It's very important.
>> So, because we all share
>> We all share the earth, we all share the
water of the earth, we all share the
food on the earth.
And so, what afflicts one species
can afflict all the other species. So,
it's not it's just just uh
something a hobby
to deal with this. This is just the the
whole
idea of doing
um on that one project at first in my of
my um
post-doctoral fellowships.
We did 30,000 autopsies in humans,
and 17,000 autopsies on animals over 462
species, I think it was, yeah.
452 species, yeah. So,
I know on some of your research, Dr.
Wallach, your task was to find the
canary in the mine.
That's correct. I was to find the animal
would would feel
first of all the species on earth, they
would show us first what was going on
with pollution.
The canary in the mine.
Yeah.
And and you definitely were very
successful at that. Um to go from saving
the white rhino and then asked to be
part of um
the Yerkes Primate Center and working
with their projects and the rhesus
monkey
where you actually found the first
non-human case of cystic fibrosis.
You submitted the slides not telling
them that it was from a my monkey.
They confirmed it was cystic fibrosis.
You also And then you exposed that pa-
it's not a human genetic disease
because you also proved that
all the different monkeys from those
colonies not related also had cystic
fibrosis.
And it was nutritional.
So, how did you come up with the fact
that it's a
nutritional deficiency disease?
Well,
this is why I came up with the book, The
Truth About Nutrition.
And people know this. When they ask
a doctor, medical doctor, "What should I
eat?"
They say, "Oh, just eat well, you'll get
everything you need." "Should I be
taking any vitamins and minerals?" "Nah,
don't waste your money on vitamins and
minerals, just eat well, you'll get
everything you need."
Well, those doctors should have their
licenses suspended and they are taking
away. They should go back to school for
a year
and be handcuffed
to the
laboratory. Okay? To where they're going
to learn about the truth about
nutrition. Yeah, this book, The Truth
About Nutrition goes into all the things
you learn
about human nutrition when you study
animal nutrition.
Um again, I studied animal nutrition
over 462 species of animals and all
those diseases occurred in humans, too.
Okay? So, I was learning everything I
could about what was going on in the
world and it was a universal thing. It
wasn't just human genetic diseases and
doctors wanted you to believe they were
genetic diseases. Okay? And
One thing that I like about how how that
book is written, Dr. Wallach, is it's
easy to understand. It lays out the
basics
and it can actually be used
um in homeschooling
when it comes to the nutrition part of
it and and teaching kids about how to
keep themselves healthy
and well.
So, I am so glad that you
wrote that one as well. Thank you.
You're a blessing in sharing
information. Thank you. I want to go
back to just just one or two sentences
from the book The Truth About Nutrition.
>> [clears throat]
>> Go to um
the chapter entitled Misplaced Trust
chapter five.
The first paragraph tells it all.
The first paragraph tells it all. It's a
short little paragraph, two or three
sentences.
Let's look at Morse scorecards
and see whether we're getting the
biggest bang for the buck. Right now
the entire world right now
Rebecca, are you sitting down?
Okay, right now
>> I'm sitting.
Right now
the entire world each year spends $2.7
trillion.
Okay?
For health care.
United States alone each year spends
$1.6 trillion.
Okay?
We spend more than half of what the
world spends for health care. We rank
17th in longevity and health. There's 16
other countries
who do better than we do
even though they may be like 50th on the
list or something like that and we
um we we don't do very well because
doctors' primary goal is to make you
feel good in two or three hours.
Cuz they know
they will give you a a great hug if
you're a doctor. "Oh, I was suffering
for years. I went to doctor so-and-so
and he gave me these pills and in a half
hour all my pain was gone after 25
years."
And then two years later they die
because they were just the doctor was
just getting rid of the symptom.
And that's mostly what doctors
um
programs do is relieve the symptoms
which brings
respect from the patient to the doctor
and there's nothing wrong with that. We
also have to give them longevity. And
that's why I wrote the book Hell's
Kitchen.
And um
let's see here.
That that one right here.
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah.
Yesterday we sold 1,000 copies of that
book.
That's fantastic, Dr. Wallach. We sold
1,000 copies of the book Hell's Kitchen.
Okay? Chapter 14
goes into the entire
the entire chapter goes into metabolic
syndrome.
Okay, which goes back to the Bible days
2,000 years ago. Very simple nutritional
deficiency
you get
um and it's all in in chapter 14 of the
book Hell's Kitchen, you get abdominal
obesity
you get type two diabetes, you get high
blood pressure
and then there's also uh 50 different
non-fatal diseases that you can get to
go along with there you go with
metabolic syndrome cuz your immune
system is low.
And you're running all these doctors and
specialists are doing surgery and this
and that and the other. And really what
you need is the book Metabolic Syndrome
and the book It's On Your Head.
And those two
books
can add 25 to 50 healthy years to your
life
and eliminate
help you eliminate most
diseases because they're not genetic
There are no genetically transmitted
diseases. I'll repeat that, there's no
genetically trans- If your doctor says
you have a genetically transmitted
disease you need to go visit several
other doctors because that doctor
doesn't know what he or she are talking
about.
Well, and that just leads us to this
book, Dr. Wallach, Epigenetics.
Epigenetics is the death of the genetic
theory of disease transmission, folks.
Epigenetics is a real science.
A science that proves that your
environment
and what you have around you and what
you put in you makes a huge difference
on
how your wellness is going to be.
And Dr. Wallach is considered one of the
founding fathers of this science of
epigenetics.
With through all of his studies, he has
also I know that look. He has also
received the Klaus Schwarz Award in 2011
for his study on specifically selenium.
And
he sued the FDA eight times with
victories
to be able for not just
but other doctors, other companies to be
able to say that specific nutrients can
benefit the body. Yeah, just let me
interrupt here.
The reason why I was given the Klaus
Schwarz Award in that one study or that
was a $21 million grant. That was my
first pathology grant. $21
or excuse me, $12 million.
And
it's um
uh we were we were able to get rid of
cystic fibrosis, which you just talked
about. We were able to get rid of
muscular dystrophy, which is Jerry's
kids, muscular dystrophy.
And we were able to get rid of
sudden infant death syndrome. The first
two
okay, cystic fibrosis and muscular
dystrophy were thought to be genetic
diseases by the medical doctors.
And the most terrible thing
most terrible thing, sudden infant death
syndrome, medical doctors published
it was caused by mothers laying on their
babies and suffocating them.
So many mothers committed suicide
because their families went after them
because the doctors told them that the
mother had laid on the baby and
suffocated them.
Well, and sad part about it, Doc, is
some of those kids, they weren't even in
the same bed with their moms and that
was why it was also termed as crib
death.
So, there's a lot of things that we as
individuals, empowered individuals, can
do
when it comes to our health and wellness
for ourselves, our families including
our pets and those
um ones that give us unconditional love.
So, I believe that since they are
continually giving us unconditional
love, we should show the same to them,
investing into their wellness.
And Dr. Wallach
I have several people that are just
ecstatic with the results that their
pets have seen
from following your recommendations.
In fact, I do have one person on with us
today. So, let me see if I can get her
unmuted. Um
Miriam?
Let me see if I can find you.
Uh-oh, did we lose her?
There she is.
You're unmuted. Hello,
Hold on. Okay, can you hear me?
Yes, ma'am.
So, share with us a little bit about
Jingles
and what Jingles is was dealing with
what, a year, a year and a half ago? And
how Jingles is doing now.
Hi, Dr. Wallach. Um yes, I just like to
let everyone know Youngevity products
have been a lifesaver for um my dog. And
um let's see, in the last two years
actually, Youngevity products has healed
her knees. She had flip knees. She did
have two cataract surgeries.
Um her kidney disease is completely gone
from Ultimate Daily Classic.
So, where we're at now is and all her
gray hair is going. She's looking
younger at for 11-year-old Cavalier King
Charles. So, Dr. Wallach, what I need
your help with so much so is how to get
this enlarged heart. She's a D2 and it's
causing her to cough.
And um she's on Ultimate Daily Classic
still one and a half a day. She's a
19-lb dog. She's on ArthryDex Perpetual,
Z-Radical. She takes the FucoQuiD Z and
the Z-Radical. GlucoGel saved her life.
She's still on three a day. Ultimate
EFAs. She's on two a day. Selenium one a
day. You just added about a year ago two
D-Stress, which is helping her sleep
through the night and she's not coughing
at night, but during the day she still
coughs.
And two Cardio FX.
Um CoQ10 two a day. She's taking all of
these products with no stomach problems,
perfect blood work. The only thing we've
got is this enlarged heart that she sees
the cardiologist every uh four months
for and they keep um doing an echo to
see how she's doing.
What can we do for her to get that heart
to shrink? It hasn't enlarged anymore,
but that's where we're at and she loves
all the products. Okay. And of course
she loves the products cuz you're giving
it to her and she's very grateful.
>> [laughter]
>> Yes. Okay. Anyway, yeah, the D-Stress is
very very important.
And um I I created this product D-Stress
because um I was invited I was invited
to very special things. One was uh
dealing uh with gorillas and the other
one was dealing with
um
I'll see here.
>> Dolphins. Dolphins, thank you. Dolphins.
And both of them were getting congestive
heart failure
and dying of congestive heart, which is
a large heart, congestive heart failure.
And I did autopsies on them
and they didn't have any genetic
diseases, um but what what I found in
their blood test
was they were just being whacked,
okay, with something called nitrates.
They're getting um things like bologna
and salami and hot dogs and things like
that. The dogs uh they were getting
those things. And of course they were
getting nitrates in bologna and salami
and things like that to the gorillas. Um
And the dolphins were eating the fish
the
the in the um um
aquarium.
So, we changed their diet, got rid of
all the nitrates
and and got them on the 90 Essential
Nutrients and I created the D-Stress
capsules for them.
And within weeks all the deaths from the
dolphins in the uh aquariums around the
world stopped.
And
uh all the all the deaths in the
gorillas and monkeys stuff like that
uh stopped.
And so this
>> heart failure? I'm sorry?
So, congestive heart failure was one of
the main reasons
that
you created D-Stress. That's correct. It
was the reason I created D-Stress.
Okay? Yeah.
>> And so but it's it works for many many
things. But when you when you're doing
things they have desserts and stuff like
that and frequently and three times a
day
you're getting all those nitrates,
you're getting uh some
uh green leafy vegetables. Uh farmers
put a lot of put a big load of of
nitrate fertilizer to get more
uh tons per per acre.
Okay? And so
it's affecting inflicting people too who
eat eat those vegetables that have a lot
of nitrates in them.
So, everybody should be taking the
D-Stress capsules. I take three of these
twice a day.
And
uh it's one of those things
where you know
a couple of dollars a day to prevent
congestive heart failure.
Believe me, it's worth it. It's worth
it.
So, Doc um Jingles has had some great
great results in overcoming some things.
And folks, this is a reminder, the
Youngevity products themselves do not
heal or cure anything, but the nutrients
within them have proven documentation.
Uh you can look it up on pubmed.gov,
but the nutrients within them have
proven
that they are beneficial for specific
conditions. And whenever you have them
synergistically blended so that they're
working together, the body gets fast
results. Now, Jingles is still
um you know working with an enlarged
heart. So, is there anything that can be
done? And and what should do for that
that daytime cough?
Well, again, uh I didn't I didn't hear
in that cuz you went down that list. Uh
what about Ultimate Daily Classic
tablets? Yes. She is on Ultimate Daily
Classic and that's been a Okay. That's
been a huge blessing for her. Okay,
good. Well, the cough could be due to a
lung thing, it could be due to a heart
thing.
Okay? But the D-Stress, I would go up to
say two twice a day.
How much does that dog weigh, do you
know? 19 lbs. 19 lbs. Yeah, I'd go two
twice a day.
And um
the
um
what should I say?
We also have oxygen, liquid oxygen,
OxyBody.
OxyBody?
Okay.
>> Yeah, so if it is a lung issues, that
that would be beneficial. Now, the heart
is a muscle, Dr. Wallach. With it being
a muscle, what can be done to help
strengthen that muscle?
Well, again, We don't want to overload
it. We just want to strengthen it. Yeah.
Yeah, again, the Ultimate Daily Classic
tablets, we needed more selenium.
Uh say if weighing 17 lbs or something
like that you say? 19 lbs.
>> 19 lbs.
>> She's taking one selenium a day, so is
it okay to
>> I'd go to two selenium a day. One in the
one in the morning, one in the evening.
You know, say 6 8 10 hour separation
between the two. And
>> [clears throat]
>> the um
OxyBody, it tastes pretty good. Even
little kids like it. So, the dog should
have a little cup and let them
drink it right out of your hand kind of
thing. You know, maybe a half ounce a
day.
And
especially before bedtime if he's
coughing at night.
Okay.
All right, so I don't think we've tried
that one, Mary. Um um
So, thank you so much for coming on and
sharing with us an update on Jingles. We
appreciate that. And appreciate you.
And another one, Dr. Wallach, and this
was shared during our team meeting
yesterday. Um Shelby had came on and uh
she has Lily. Lily is a Great Pyrenees,
11 years old, and 3 years ago was
diagnosed with that big awful C word
that's five letters. Um
and she was like, I can't lose my baby.
So, we got Lily on a program. Um it was
about a year had another more testing
and
nothing was found. Now, 3 years later,
she's still just as happy as ever and
acting like a puppy.
Um so, Lily is doing well as well as a
Great Pyrenees. So, I wanted to thank
Shelby for sharing that with us. What
was the core what were the core products
she was using? What was the core product
she was using tonight?
Four products that Lily was on.
ArthryDex.
Okay? ArthryDex is the multivitamin
mineral with enzymes designed for
animals. Now, this can be given to dogs,
cats, birds, horses, all the above. It
includes kind of like the 90 Essential
Nutrients for humans.
It is designed for our pets.
Does not have the essential fatty acids
in it, so we still have to do the EFAs,
which Lily was taking the essential
fatty acids. She was also taking some
selenium, which I think she was taking
two or three a day, Dr. Wallach.
And
she was also taking the FucoQuiD Z,
which has fucoidan in it. So, folks,
look up fucoidan and all the benefits of
fucoidan.
It is incredible what fucoidan itself
can do.
And there's something else that I'm
missing.
Um oh, she had some tumors.
And this this can apply for dogs, not
necessarily for cats, but with those
tumors, she applied frankincense
essential oil. Just a little bit on
those tumors and she she doesn't have
any tumors today. So,
she has done great things and all of
these things can be found on our website
or through your Youngevity associate or
certified holistic health coach. Um if
you're looking for the website, it's
dailywithdoc.com.
Dr. Wallach, we have some hands up. So,
let's go ahead and go to Ann first. Ann,
go ahead and unmute yourself.
Hello there.
>> to Hello.
Thank you. Um hi, Dr. Wallach. Um my dog
is um
5 years old. He's a golden doodle uh and
he 57 lb.
And he has an ear infection.
And um he's had it probably for about 2
weeks, and it's getting a little bit
better with the um
medication that the vet gave us. Um I
was wondering, can I put colloidal
silver in there?
Well, you get an A+.
Okay. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you.
>> you go ahead and put a couple of
droppers full down in the dog's ears,
let her shake it.
Okay? Uh but um you can do that two,
three times a day.
Uh the colloidal silver doesn't sting
even if there's an open wound in the ear
canal. Uh they cuz sometimes they'll
scratch their ears and cause a little
open wound.
And so um but there's there's no alcohol
in it.
Uh tastes like water, looks like water,
smells like water.
But it kills
all bacteria, viruses, fungus, and
yeast.
Oh, okay, great. Yeah, that was that was
just wondering about that because it's
deep in there. So, and I figured
colloidal silver, you know, since it's
the liquid, it would get deep down in
there.
Awesome. It comes in a dropper bottle.
And
And so you say 57 lb.
And so the um
colloidal silver
you're looking at
Yeah, Doc has Doc has almost everything
on his desk.
Desk, folks.
And no matter where he's at, his
nutrition and all of his
first aid kit
are close to him even at the even at the
breakfast table.
So, yeah, the colloidal silver is
awesome. Just a few drops, you can put
it under the tongue, you can put it in
the ears. And Doc, I've even used it for
eye infections for my animals and my
kids and myself. Just a couple drops in
the Yeah, because it doesn't have any
alcohol or any chemicals. It's just
Yeah. colloidal silver.
Awesome. Thank you so much. Well, thank
you, Karen. Give us a call in a couple
of weeks. Let us know. People want to
know what's going on.
Okay, I will do. Thank you.
>> Thank you, Anne.
And next, let's go to a question that
came in from I think Facebook.
Um and there So, Ted is says, "Can a dog
with existing joint damage in his back,
knee joints
from arthritis damage be reversed?"
Well,
from a standpoint of taking
a nutritional program, it can rebuild
broken bones and
uh torn cartilage and
uh kind of connective tissue, uh that
kind of stuff, no problem.
Uh but the leg may heal, be a little
twisted, and it may not be in the right
position, but it can certainly heal the
joints. And um
the
um
ArthryDex
we keep it here in the house. If
anything goes wrong with the shipment of
our human stuff, I just eat the
ArthryDex.
So, it does have a beef flavor, folks.
And yes, I have tasted it myself. I am
so thankful that I keep at least 6
months of Beyond Tangy Tangerine on hand
at all times, and so does Doc. Plus,
actually he does probably a year.
But
the ArthryDex can do some amazing stuff.
And so with arthritis, Doc, in humans,
we also add in the GlucoGel and the MSM
Ultra. Those things, are they
appropriate for animals as well? Oh,
absolutely. GlucoGel is a product that I
created. Okay, for Theo Ratliff, the
basketball player. We took our
the start pack and made it the healthy
bone and joint pack by creating the
GlucoGel to add to it.
And we solved all his bone joint
problems, didn't have to have surgery.
And in the next um 9 years, he made $100
million in contracts that rebuilt him.
Okay? I think I think his family might
be
thankful.
>> they might want to use the ArthryDex.
Yeah.
So, with ArthryDex, it is 10 per or 1
per 10 lb. So, depending on the weight
of the pet,
it is can be dosed at 1 per 10 lb up to
150 lb where you're doing five three
times a day. And that's the same for
humans. That's actually what I myself
did
um when I was first getting started
because I had so many bone and joint
issues, including uh degeneration of the
discs, Doc.
Um
So, amazing stuff. The MSM Ultra also
works on
bones, connective tissue, and reduces
inflammation.
I'm sorry. So,
and it reduces inflammation.
Yeah. MSM is a great anti-inflammatory.
Also, it has the raw materials, and of
course, also for dogs,
uh they can consider I I think there's
an I-26 product
for pets. Perpetual Plus. Yes, Perpetual
Plus has antioxidants.
Um it has some essential fatty acids and
the I-26, which helps with clearing the
body of parasites and pathogens and
giving what the liver needs in far as
the good cholesterol to help protect the
brain and the nerves. Even a dog has
brains
and spinal cords, same way with rabbits
and any pigs and monkeys. Uh all mammals
require
that I-26. So, Perpetual Plus is a great
thing for animals. It's a little cheaper
than than the um
uh one for humans. Okay? I-26. And it's
in a chewable that absolutely love.
Absolutely love.
So, Dr. Wallach, we have another
question here that is coming in.
Um and
let me see. That one was a
Let's go to a hand that is raised.
So, let's go up to
Now, I don't know why
Let's go to Gloria. Hello, Gloria. Go
ahead and unmute yourself.
Hello, Dr. Wallach and Becca. Hello.
Hello.
Hey, I have a question. I have a
customer who's taking the 2.5 Tangy
Tangerine, and she says that since she's
been taking it, she has noticed
increased urination. She's finding
herself having to rush to the restroom.
Is this something that happens when um
you're taking the 2.5 Tangy Tangerine,
or could it be something else?
Um so, you gave it to the dog for what
purpose? Oh, no, it's it's a human.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, it's a human.
Yeah, we're doing the two-legged animal,
Doc.
Yeah, well, the Tangy Tangerine Uh-huh.
is is a great product.
And I take I I take three of those twice
a day myself.
And I only weigh 142 lb.
It's one of those things where you're
looking at anti-inflammatory, you're
looking it kills bugs, it supports your
immune system.
And um
uh I like to again take it when people
are having trouble with their vision,
their hearing, uh swallowing, taste, all
that kind of stuff.
Cuz they may have something going on
like it's all in your head. Okay? So,
they need the 90 essential nutrients,
and then all the little extra things
that you're talking about would help
speed up the healing.
Okay? Yeah.
Yeah, uh she's saying that it's
increasing her urination. Is that
something that normally happens? Yeah,
it's not unusual when people take
supplements, they're going to have
extra.
Okay?
Because suddenly now, they're getting
So, they're getting 16 minerals, they're
getting 60.
Okay? Okay. Three vitamins, they're
getting
As you pour nutrition into the machine,
it's kind of like when you pour
um
uh extra
sort of support for
increasing the the
uh power of your gasoline,
uh you can do more because you
it produces more power.
Okay, so increased urination is is
normal.
Yeah, when when you're taking
supplements, it's not abnormal.
Okay. All right, thank you. You bet.
Keep us informed.
Okay.
All right. God bless.
Uh you, too.
All right. And one thing, if I may add,
Dr. Wallach, especially if they're on uh
like the Ultimate Daily Classic,
that's
creating that circulation through the
body and clearing things out so that the
the urine is able to take the toxins out
of the body
efficiently. Correct? That's correct.
The
>> [clears throat]
>> Ultimate Daily Classic is your heart and
your kidneys and your lungs and your
brain's best friend.
Okay, it gets the it gets the blood
flowing through blocked arteries.
Takes down the inflammation in the
arteries.
Helps you get rid of the poisons through
the urine.
And when you're making your kidneys
happy,
your blood pressure comes down.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay, cuz your kidneys are involved with
regulating blood pressure as well as
urine flow and stuff like that.
All right. Well, let's go to Phyllis who
has her hand up. Hello, Phyllis.
Hello, Doc. Hi, Phyllis. We're back to
the animal world again. We have a dog
question.
>> [laughter]
>> Um a woman has in
um, she's not on the Zoom, but uh she
phoned in a question about her 15-lb dog
that has dry skin. What's going to help
that dog?
Well, that's an easy one.
I mean, you need to make sure
to look at the dog food,
okay? [clears throat]
And make sure that it does have
essential fatty acids in it.
If it doesn't have essential fatty acids
in it, we have the EFAs, the EFA Plus's.
15-lb dog, I would I would give that dog
one EFA, one EFA Plus.
But also, we have hair, skin, and nails.
Mhm.
Mhm, that's not just for people, it's
for any critter with hair.
Hair, skin, and nails.
Okay?
And I love hair, skin, and nails. I take
three of those twice a day.
You know, you should see my kitchen
table
where I get put.
>> [laughter]
>> Cooks, you know, Malan and
uh Rebecca and everybody else who are
cooking, they point to the table, I sit
down.
Well, where I sit
I have 50 different bottles of of
supplements.
50 different bottles of our supplements,
Young Living supplements. We have 2,500.
I couldn't get 2,500 on the table, so I
just picked the top.
>> [clears throat]
>> I I picked the top 50.
And I take
one, two, three a day of each one,
depending on which one it is.
And again
um you know, I'm 75 years old. Most
people think I'm
um 50 when they look at me.
You can't be 80
years old. Well, I am.
I I'm not surprised, and you should see
our kitchen counter behind me. It's just
loaded, loaded up.
Uh by the way, that uh um pet food it's
also important for people to get the
gluten-free pet food, right?
Yeah, it's got to be gluten-free
because it kills your intestines in any
mammal
just like it kills the intestines of
humans.
Whether it's dog, cat, rat, rabbit
any pig
Okay, and any critter, monkey
um you can't You got to read the label.
And you got to read the label carefully
on the book MSM
because
because it says [clears throat]
contains, and then one of the first
things in there is
um
wheat.
But there's a a fine little letter after
the word it contains
and O. Contains no
gluten or wheat. Okay?
But it's in real tiny letters, and it's
easy to read past it all those bigger
words.
So, it's just letting you know that it
doesn't contain any of the bad stuff.
MSM. So, I take three of those twice a
day also in addition to the GlucoGel.
And again
85 years old I can take on two or three
guys at one time. I don't care if
they're bigger than me, but I'll be
faster than them.
Doc, one more comment if I would. Uh
sometimes people tell me, "Well, I give
my pet such and such people food, you
know, I give them this and that." And I
I hear that's a no-no.
Well, it disrupts the percentages of
vitamins and minerals to food.
Okay?
Again, you need minerals, vitamins,
minerals and fatty acids.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um
and it's one of those things where
the ArthryDex is a great way to balance
everything out.
And when you read the label in dog food
be sure especially in cat and dog food
make sure there's uh
no wheat, rye, or rye oats, no buckwheat
no gluten.
Okay, all that's got to go.
And it's one of those things where it's
an enormous difference in their health,
their energy, their longevity
if they're going to have uh three babies
in a litter or 12.
That kind of thing. And so
um
you have a lot of control over what goes
into
And don't forget that I-26
for okay?
The I-26.
Thank you, Doc.
All right, thank you, Phyllis. Now, Dr.
Wallach, I've been trying to get my fur
babies to come in to the screen, but
I've taught them not to jump on me. So,
they're just they're just not
cooperating. Um but I have three adult
ArthryDex babies and then there's six
Oh, I should have had them bring one of
the puppies. Six ArthryDex baby babies.
Um and they love the part the Perpetual
Plus and the dog companion, another
product that is a chewable for our
animals that is just absolutely
fantastic.
Now Coach Wright is on the phone right
now with a gentleman who's calling about
his mother, so we're going to the human
pets, Doc.
Um he loves his mom. She's She's 75
years old. She's 5'5".
And she has been diagnosed with
supraventricular
tachy- uh
tachycardia.
So, they're wanting to know what would
>> she's got tachycardia?
So, it's called supraventricular
tachycardia. Okay, so it's the upper
part of the ventricles.
Okay?
Or Okay.
fast. Okay, so again
got to get rid of all the bad stuff. No
fried foods, no processed meats, no
oils, no glutens, no wheat, rye, or rye
oats, no buckwheat, no sugar, no
carbonated drinks. Even that one's got
to go.
And you say she weighs
how much?
Let's go by 125 lbs.
Okay, mom weighs 125 lbs.
Okay. 5'5".
5'5".
And I'd have her take
>> [clears throat]
>> 125 lbs, I'd have her take um one
Healthy Brain and Heart pack per month.
Have those at breakfast, have those at
dinnertime. I also want her to have
the Cardio FX.
She'd take two doses a day of that. Just
read the label.
Two doses [clears throat] a day of the
Cardio FX.
She also needs the Ultimate Daily
Classic tablets to get circulation into
the heart.
And then for the valves, everybody
always forgets the valves which are made
out of connective tissue, the same thing
that that um
makes your your cartilage in your knees
and your hips and uh tendons.
GlucoGel and MSM.
Just label for dosage for weight.
All right, so MSM, three twice a day,
and GlucoGel
um up to five a day or three three times
a day? Yeah. All right.
So, thank you so much for that, Dr.
Wallach. Greatly appreciate that. Now,
we have another question.
And it has to do with a kit a cat with
kidney failure. So, so she's
feline kidney failure, Dr. Wallach.
The cat Oh, and then uh
um AJ put in the put in as a question
mark for the uh tachycardia. Would you
recommend De-Stress for that as well?
Same cat?
No, we're going back to the human.
Uh the 75-year-old woman that you just
for the
>> Ultimate Daily Classic, absolutely.
Good for the heart.
>> And how about De-Stress?
Would De-Stress De-Stress would that be
beneficial for them?
>> De-Stress De-Stress could be beneficial,
absolutely.
And it's a matter of, you know, their
budget and what's primary, and then you
can add on the add-ons.
All right, thank you so much. Um now
Oh, and AJ asked, "Becca, have you
noticed larger litters with the
nutrients?"
So, folks, we've had
it we've had 16 pups in one litter.
Yeah. And only one
>> Nutrition.
Bad nutrition
might give you one dead puppy. Okay?
Good nutrition could give you 16 puppies
healthy.
Well, Doc, we
we had 16 healthy puppies until mama
laid on one.
And that was really sad, but 16 puppies
all the way to the end, so
it's crazy. It's
you know, I'm I'm happy with you know,
four or five per litter.
But even this last one was nine. It's
crazy.
Um so, let's go to feline
kidney disease, Dr. Wallach.
Okay.
>> here's one of them.
Needs the Ultimate Daily Classic
tablets.
Ultimate Daily Classic tablets. That's
not a feline.
No, not feline, but it's a female.
Okay, so Okay. So, the cat Okay, um
>> [clears throat]
>> one
Ultimate Daily Classic tablet per day.
If it's a tiny cat, you can just break
it in half, give it half in the morning,
half at night.
Okay?
>> [clears throat]
>> But the Ultimate Daily Classic tablets
is your kidney's best friend.
Ultimate Daily Classic It blocks
arteries, takes blocked arteries, gets
circulation going through blocked
arteries.
And that way people have
Yeah, I used to, you know, urinate maybe
two or three times a day. Now, I'm
urinating once a day. I don't know
what's going on. Well, that's because
the arteries are getting clogged
to take the blood and the dirty blood
and all that kind of stuff into the
kidney. It can't
work if it's not getting the stuff out
of the kidney and if the kidney's
uh blocked
This is you
classic tablets.
And again, if it's And and typical cat,
just break one in half, give give the
cat a half down the throat.
Um you know, in the morning and then one
again before dinner at night.
And then cats like fish. What about
essential fatty acids and taking and
puncturing one of those essential fatty
acids and putting it in its Absolutely,
ArthryDex.
And ArthryDex, absolutely.
Yeah, ArthryDex is good for cats and
dogs and monkeys and
um, rabbits and and
all kinds of critters.
And the puppies love it. Wait, that's
how we get them to um start eating solid
foods is we put that ArthryDex on there
and we mix it up and they just start
licking it off the kibble and then start
eating the kibble and just absolutely
love it.
Now, let's talk about we only have 4
minutes, Doc. Plant-derived minerals,
what are the importance of making sure
that our pets are getting minerals in a
form that can be absorbed like the
colloidal minerals?
Okay, well, plant-derived colloidal
minerals
and we have mineral this plant-derived
colloidal minerals from eight different
mines from around the world.
We have products that have a a minimum
of 75 minerals and we have some products
with minerals that go up to 100
minerals, okay? Um,
some puppy dogs and cats will turn their
heads up if you put I like to put a
little bit of the plant-derived liquid
minerals uh in, you know, say maybe a
teaspoon into their water dish. Uh some
will drink it and some won't. The ones
that won't drink it, what you do is you
hold them in your arms, put them on
their back and rub the plant-derived
colloidal minerals, maybe a teaspoon
under their belly every day.
And then they'll go in a corner sit down
and they'll lick their belly themselves
>> [clears throat]
>> and some will be absorbed through the
skin and some will be absorbed through
their tongue. So, there you go. But the
plant-derived colloidal minerals,
um, this is
how much I say
is where people lived a long time,
uh the land flowing with milk and honey.
Why did people live to be 120, 150 in
certain areas? That's because they were
getting the the colloidal minerals
from the
mountains grinding up the rocks at the
top. The rock dust, which was white,
would get into the streams coming down
the side of the mountain and look like
milk. So, the farmers 2,000 years ago
thought it was cow's milk. No, it was
glacial milk.
It was rock melt milk, okay?
And the people who drank their water
from the
uh colloidal minerals, okay? Okay, the
um
rock minerals, uh also, they got uh
minerals in their food, in their
cooking, uh in their drinking water
and so forth. And so, uh also in the
plants that grew where I were irrigated.
And so, you see back in the old days,
uh back before 1812, everybody was
putting wood ashes and coal ashes into
their gardens and into their food.
Once electricity came, everybody got
lazy. No, no, no, don't don't don't
waste your time putting wood ashes in
the garden. Okay?
Just you got electricity, you don't need
to have it. I was there thinking it's
just it drives the plants to grow more,
but it doesn't realize that the plants
were keeping the minerals. So, when you
ate those plants, you were getting the
minerals.
And so, this is why I suddenly
there were hospitals. There's no
hospitals
500 years ago.
The doctor would come by your house with
a handful of herbs.
Okay, and have dinner with House calls.
Yeah. Okay, yeah, house visits. And so,
the hospitals and uh health insurance
only came along after 1812 when they
came up with electricity and there was
no more wood ashes or coal ashes to add
to your uh food and your gardens and it
really was devastating for human health.
And so,
um
people who invented
uh electricity,
um
did a good thing on one hand, but on the
other hand, they have killed more people
than all the wars combined.
Cause and effect. Cause and effect, Doc.
Well, Dr. Wallach, we are at at the top
of the hour. Do you have time for one
more question? One more question.
Okay, so we have a question and Enrique
is wanting to know what would you
recommend for a human
with the symptoms of Parkinson's?
Ah, we need to get the the um flip
chart,
page [clears throat] 26 on the flip
chart. It tells the story of Madeline.
And Madeline had Parkinson's disease
for, I don't know, 10, 12 years,
something like that.
>> 11 years. 11 years
>> 11, okay.
And she was going to her neurologist at
a big famous medical university in
Maryland
like three or four times a year.
>> Illinois.
Yeah. Chicago.
And then
we got her on the program because one of
is is a member of Youngevity, is there
anything we do for her? Cuz, you know,
she's coming to her end. So, we came up
with a program,
okay, for her.
And guess what?
It's the I26.
The I26
>> I26 Yeah, we made that. Yeah, we made
that.
Okay? So
And we gave it to her, rebuilt her brain
and in 2 and 1/2 months
she went for her regular
um
exam. Three yearly exam. And the doctor
said, "Well, you you registered
negative. That can't be right." For the
first time in 25 years, you know, or 12
years, whatever it is, uh 12 years. Uh
let's have her come back tomorrow. We'll
reset all the machinery. Well, they
reset all the machinery, she came back
the next day.
Still. So, we
>> Yeah, we got rid of it in in 2 months, 2
months and a week. And so, now that
story got out, I actually submitted that
story to a couple of magazines like New
York Ti- you know, the New York Times
and that kind of stuff.
Magazines.
And they rejected them cuz the doctors
who were on the editing committee said,
"This is nonsense." They wouldn't let
them publish it.
And just a couple of days ago they they
come out, "Oh, we we may have found
something that's going to help
Parkinson's disease now."
Well, and exactly what she was taking,
Dr. Wallach. So, she was on the healthy
start pack. Yes. She was taking
selenium, ultimate selenium, uh
three per day. She was also taking
ultimate daily classic And
>> and Synaptiv And and I26, the knowledge
>> yep.
To rebuild
>> twice a day. Yep. And and that
>> to stop taking She had to stop taking
the doctors were giving her the pills to
get rid of all the
um Yeah, they told her Well, they told
her she didn't need them anymore, Dr.
Wallach, because she no longer had the
symptoms. That You no longer had
elevated blood
She no longer had the symptoms
associated with the Parkinsonism and
they told her she could stop taking
So, I think that's a win.
>> Why was she taking those tablets?
To lower cholesterol.
The the prescriptions? She she Yeah, she
The physicians gave her pills to lower
her cholesterol.
And that's why she got Parkinson's
disease. Parkinson's disease is a
cholesterol deficiency.
And when that happened at that time
point in time,
the rate
of Parkinson's disease in America had
been 60,000 per year in America.
Once they started giving them pills to
lower their cholesterol, blood
cholesterol, it jumped up to 90,000,
went up 50%
because they're pushing all the
cholesterol out of their bodies and they
couldn't make myelin for the white
matter of the brain and spinal cord
anymore.
Shame on the doctors.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Um shame on them and that's why we put
this program together
you can do as solutions to help correct
those deficiencies that are causing
disease. So, with the 90 essential
nutrients that Dr. Wallach has developed
through autopsies and looking at those
autopsies and all the mineral
compositions that are found within them
and connecting the dots with the disease
that was also found in those individuals
that he was doing the autopsies on, he
came up with this list of 90 essential
nutrients.
Well, folks, 60 of those are minerals.
And when you look at how many different
poor health conditions
are directly linked to nutritional
deficiencies, you're looking upwards of
different poor health conditions. Dr.
Wallach talks about them in in one of
the the best-selling books ever, The
Greatest Lecture
Ever Given is also of the same title,
Dead Doctors Don't Lie. Thank you, Dr.
Wallach, for holding that up for me. I
think mine fell on the other side of the
desk. Um but
you know, when you've got over 400
million copies sold of a lecture and the
book is right there behind it,
you you got to take notice.
What is being said are things that are
empowering you as an individual to take
your health back. We're not chemical
deficient. We're nutrient deficient.
Farming practices
it and and it's not so much the farmer's
part a pro um
fault, okay? I'm surrounded by farmers.
I love the farmers around me.
Some of my greatest friends.
But, when a plant only needs three
nutrients
to thrive,
that's what they get.
We as individuals need 90.
And if the minerals are not in the soil,
they're not going to be in the plants
that we're eating.
Or in the plants
that the animals are eating, that then
we eat
the byproducts of.
So, we must be intentional for ourselves
and our pets in making sure that we're
getting daily. It's like putting gas in
a car. You run out of gas, your car's
not going to go anywhere.
Oil goes dry,
you're going to blow it up.
We have to be intentional each and every
day in making sure that we are investing
in ourselves, in our families, and our
communities, including our pets.
So, that together
we can make a healthier world. Now, I
have some amazing co-hosts on with me
today. If they could go ahead and bring
themselves on the screen with me,
um we couldn't do this without them as
they are helping in getting this message
out and reaching every corner of the
world that I am so thankful that we are
reaching every corner of the world and
technology is absolutely fantastic,
especially when you have people that
know how to use it.
And get us out there.
So, I usually end with this individual.
I just wanted to say thank you, AJ, for
all the work that you've done in getting
us on all these different platforms.
Um
as the executive the assistant to the
executive production manager and our
social media um specialist, I just want
to say thank you, thank you, thank you
um for that.
Um and he hates attention. That's that's
why we're doing this.
Um we also want to say thank you to
those that are out and on social media
platforms, bringing in those questions,
answering the questions, and creating
some momentum there. We have Phyllis,
who is out um asking questions, keeping
an eye on things. We have coach Rob
doing the same. And so, I want to thank
both of them for all that they do and
also answering the phones as as we had a
one of the questions come in today from
somebody on the phone, bringing it in.
We also have Sherry, um who is part of
our tech crew in making sure everything
gets set up properly and and streaming.
We have Ruth Ellen, who is my executive
production manager,
um keeping everything going smoothly and
running the broadcaster that then
streams it to all these different
platforms that they are watching.
We have Marilyn, who is um just
absolutely fantastic. And if you're not
in the Zoom live with us Monday through
Friday from 12:00 to 1:00 p.m. Pacific
Time, you're missing out as
she and Phyllis are both putting in
information and dictating what is being
said in the Zoom so that if you're
taking notes and you miss something,
they don't miss a thing. They've got you
covered. You can just scroll back up in
the chat and write down what you missed.
So, thank you so much, Marilyn, for
doing that.
And we have Albert, who is helping let
people into the Zoom room,
which is just as important as the others
because if people didn't come in, they
wouldn't be able to raise their hands,
they wouldn't be able to ask questions,
or be here live with us
on dailywithdoc.com.
So, thanks to my team. They are all
certified holistic health coaches. And
if you are not working with somebody,
you do you are not associated with
anybody that is affiliated with
Youngevity, and you would like to have
your own health coach or join our team
and learn how to be a health coach, make
sure that you give us a call.
855-949-3377.
That's 855-949-3377.
If you'd like more information about our
certified holistic health coach course,
please go to www.
coachwithdoc.
That's d o c. So, coachwithdoc.com,
you'll find more information about our
coaching program. And if you are looking
to figure out what is going to be the
best option for you,
you can take our health evaluation.
Again, this is for people that aren't
already working with somebody
by going to help.dailywithdoc.com.
That is help. dailywithdoc.com
and take that health evaluation based on
the current 30 days, things that you've
got going on right now. We'll make sure
that we get you connected with a
certified holistic health coach for a
free 15-minute consultation in
helping you determine what's going to be
your best route and meeting your budget
as well. So, as we do specialize in
helping people with keeping things
within their budget so that they can
continue to invest in themselves and
maintain or regain wellness.
My name is Becca Dukes. Thank you so
much for joining us.
Time is an investment as well, and you
just invested 1 hour plus in yourself,
your family, including your fur babies.
Share this program with others. Let us
know where you're joining us from on the
different platforms. And if you have
questions,
email us at questions@ dailywithdoc.com.
Even if you're in South Africa, even if
Even if you're in South Africa.
>> Even if you're in South Africa.
Absolutely.
Even if you're in South Africa. So,
Albert and is working with a gentleman
in the South Africa area, just north of
South Africa, and bringing them in as a
distributor because they too want to be
part of the solution
as we do as well.
So, thank you for saying that, Doc.
All right, everybody. Have a fabulous
day and don't forget to share this with
somebody you know and love. Bye for now.
Bye-bye, everybody. Always funny best to
talk soon. Lack of ray.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences and the
individual results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. [music]
We are honored to have a founding father
of the science of epigenetics guiding us
with the best options to obtain or
maintain optimal health, Dr. Joel
Wallach.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences and
the individual results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. [music] We are
honored to have a founding father of the
science of epigenetics guiding us with
the best options to obtain [music]
or maintain optimal health, Dr. Joel
Wallach.